[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the council's
in your plane hearing of submissions so
thank you all for being here we've got a
busy afternoon of submitters so firstly
is there any apologies no any conflicts
of interest so we'll come to item 3
which is hearing of submissions to the
draft annual clean is per the timetable
which is with intelligent systems here
so the first is the Oxford of Hoka
Community Board and so I'd like to
welcome Doug mr. dog Nichol the chair of
the board
good afternoon Doug welcome to a hearing
can you hear you're on mute Doug say
perhaps two you might be able to help
with unmuting the air dock you're on
mute now you welcome to our hearings
you've got with us all the council and
chief executive and staff so thank you
for your submission so you've got up to
20 minutes there Doug and it's to
include questions as well so take take
it that your submissions been read and
welcome you to speak to your points
obviously we're in the changed
environment and what we put out in their
draft plane we may well be changing as a
consequence of covert so just to let you
know that okay
thank you for thank you for you being
with us today and we look forward to
hearing from you all right thank you
just to start with it this was prepared
before hope at 19 years it's over the
head so it's fairly long but there's a
lot of it is still quite relevant
standing off of the upgrades and
treatment and waters the borders and
full support of their the officer esteem
the question I have is 27.5%
appreciation over the last 23 years why
is the depreciation amount taken out
still 236,000 is it not off diminishing
value moving on to the scoop it's very
important that this gets replaced as
becoming a firewall the means of getting
at a ranger earn into Christchurch and
what used to be the woody employed path
also very important heavy traffic
volumes are increasing all the time
council upgrade the go ahead here should
be consistent with prudence I think were
considered with prunes climate change in
community outcomes know who the comment
on those fresh water we need to clean up
our surface waterways for certain
sustainability know through the comment
on their waste levy the increase of
waste disposal of the increase of the
cost of waste disposal is yun of course
people have done from the side the
erosion I think we'd be able to keep the
cost of disposing waste as well as
possible
here's a review know through the common
state park in Oxford this has been an
ongoing requirement for a twist
requested for some years and under the
prison financial climate I guess we need
to wait some more but would we get good
to have something done with it the
Oxford dark pack is a another long term
project that doesn't need to progress at
this point right here
Iranian pathways I think this was taught
to pet when I first became a involve
with the Oxford Year award advisory
board sixteen years ago and it would be
good to see some positive progress
there's a lot of footpaths that don't
exist in Oxford riparian planting and no
further comment rural traffic safety
these items speak for themselves once
again they have been under this
spotlight for some years men or small
enough full support from the board on
that so I've always know who the calming
drains and flooding the bull of wishes
to promote
urgency on this project and the
Manderley area because several houses
and mandrill are subject to flooding
during high flood times and I'll put my
other step on for this with the off the
Oakland or drainage community they also
support that it needs to be fixed as
soon as possible
Brazil
here's some park lighting as a safety
issue and should be looked at as soon as
possible and the Ashley George that what
the council's done with Ashley or was
very well received and the board wishes
to thank them for that
we're set and P and I further comment
and rural communities no Twitter comment
and I would like ears at the bottom here
on the first of May last Friday the
board voted that we would quest to
retain this year's landscaping budget
for next year and that we know that we
don't wish to accept a new landscaping
grant for next year so if we can just
return what we've got would be good
thank you
this was the site on Friday 1st of May
the Arizona mucho are there any
questions thanks duck
so just open it up to questions first
I've got councillor Blakey cancer please
good are we unmuted are we good your
unusualness yes dag page 9 is the
traffic safety from issues on where
South air Road meets tram fearing in
mind that you've got a crossroads on a
corner which is you know bloody awful
but that's the way it is and bearing in
mind that we've that intersection was
rebuilt and rejigged
only a couple of years ago what what
does the committee think could be done
to improve it's a regular user neither
of I
okay well staff will consider that windy
did you have a question yet no you you
you can go on unmute now yes thanks for
much for the presentation Doug and can
you just you didn't mention about the
ashy Gorge that would be nice if I could
have a barbecue or the park
did they Community Board want that to go
forward they want to take really art
yeah go forward okay thank you thank you
any further questions attack well see
thank you Doug for your submission sorry
hold on cancer treatment Thank You doc
for coming along and being the guinea
pig on our first submission I just
wondered in terms of your submission do
you have any priorities you I would
prioritize what are the what would be
the one thing you'd really like or even
two or three things it wasn't possible
to give you everything I don't know that
we can really sort of say there as a
priority but there are I haven't gotten
my ID anything that our appreciation
sort of priority at this point Thanks
thank you any further questions all
right well thank you Doug for presenting
it on behalf of the board just to let
you quickly know that we'll be
considering the annual plan between the
26th and 28th of May with the view of
adopting it on the 16th of June so we
will communicate our decisions on the
following
that time so we'll make that clear to
you but thank you for the board's
consideration of this I'm pointing
forward
the the submission and also for offering
the view on the landscape budget we
appreciate your time and thank you thank
you
Cheers thanks jack alright so the next
is affarin really and waiting is the
wedding Sefton community board supposed
to be 20 past okay is as mister is mr.
Jared Thea from the ring Eurasian
community board you were there any other
submitters waiting no others ministers
waiting at this stage sir okay thank you
we can just we will just be in a holding
panel in the interim but just remember
team this is being recorded so just be
careful so we'll just wait until
obviously the next submitters here so
[Music]
[Music]
please show the submitter 3 good
afternoon good afternoon Shona on behalf
of the William siftin Community Board
it's great to welcome you to our
hearings this afternoon
so I see you're on mute there so you're
a little ahead of time which was really
good so thank you you've got up to 20
minutes to sub to present your
submissions your submission that
includes questions so please take it
that the submissions been read in
highlight your main points but the 20
minutes is yours whether you want to use
it for the whole time
and speaking or earlier for some
questions we'll leave it over to you but
yeah so what I start thank you for the
opportunity to present the woody and
city and community board submission to
the draft in your plan I mean these
times are the fast pace change in such a
high impact on our communities and
businesses and the farmers as well and
our board actually believes that
community boards are very well placed to
provide information and local knowledge
as council moves forth with the recovery
phase and recovery planning and we would
like to ask that community boards are
involved as much as possible at all
stages we can also help with the
dissemination of information to locals
and community groups because we have all
those links and that knowledge speaking
for our area and the William Pegasus
Area strategy was adopted in 2013 and
needs updating a lot has
and then the area since the area has
changed it's grown significantly and
work on reviewing and formulating these
strategy needs to be started many
actions identified have happened
examples are the Pegasus roundabouts and
the Gladstone Park redevelopment against
Android cycle and walkway some will not
happen some of them are change away that
our communities will connect an example
that is the kya point power road
connecting Pegasus and my coffee beat
some shut up happened that haven't
example there is safe pedestrian and
cycle nexus between body and Ravenswood
in Pegasus
so moving on our position on rate
increases this coming year is to strive
for zero but of not possible absolute
minimal increases so the board have also
a cui svet to assist on the economic
recovery of the district that council we
ever possible use local businesses and
enterprises to write goods and services
we submitted on deferring the
development of the park-and-ride and i
in the annual plan given those delays
with the completion of the Northern
Corridor project and I understand that
since being the council submission to
Environment Canterbury on their draft in
your plan has also included this the
other project that we have submitted on
previously is the ring your heart excuse
me just for a moment Shona there's some
members indication their card here is it
possible you could just get a bit closer
to the microphone if it's right sorry
yeah I can hear but there's some that
are just indicating they can't so thank
you carry on
thank you very much it's it's that's as
good as it can be it's all recorded
anyway so thank you Shona the board on
was
the irregular carpark ilding and we sort
of think in the short-term medium-term
this could be deferred one point tonight
going forward is it with the Ravenswood
commercial section area coming on the
supermarket has I can't do any better
sorry guys you don't that's fine I can
hear you fine so yeah at the supermarket
that consents you know has been gone
through is outfit tender at the moment
subcontractors so hopefully in four
months we will have a supermarket in
Ravenswood and there's going to change
the way people in this area shop and so
that wheel is going to render
unnecessarily fourth four things which
will take a bit of the pressure offering
your and although Rainier is growing
that will sort of compensate for that
one
so the Skloot ongoing projects one is
the symptom public hall they're going to
be speaking to you later this afternoon
but the board is very supportive of the
system public hall committee for those
of you not aware the second public all
it's not a council facility and it did
this up at earthquake damage and needs
to be lie the repaired or rebuilt and
but they will fill you and on on all the
details but they will need assistance
from the council whatever the community
decides that they want to do our board
the mir and community and recreations
don't have meet with the committee
earlier this year not too long before
lockdown and we would like to ensure
that council offer assistance to this
group with getting the project off the
ground we're going to point out that
sifting as a community has actually
asked for very little key council and in
the past years and we feel that this is
a really project which would mean that
the community spirit of septum is
supported and can flourish
another one that we raised in our
submission is a Pegasus life we would
really like to see this become their
year-long recreational asset better
actually deserves to be for the
community and for the whole district
we've spoke about this previously but
there's been little action to date the
lake has deteriorated in terms of the
tracking weed and algal blooms we are
looking for support and leadership from
the council to get an action plan
developed for the lake a key part of
this is that accountability for actions
as it hasn't happened so far we do
understand that it is consented for
secondary contact only but when you're
kayaking dragon boat racing or paddle
boarding the water still splashes on
your face and if you very very unlucky
you can take an unscheduled duck the
weeders a real problem premier sporting
events are hindered it can take tangle
and paddles oars and the model yacht
kills the lake has really been enjoyed
by the locals during level four and by
some of the wider community and level
three and now is the time for some
action on the lake community facilities
again we have we've spoken about this
before we have Ravenswood growing you're
looking at getting stage three hopefully
underway soon we're planning on that one
Pegasus is growing all that we ask is
that some consideration is given to
where the community facilities will go
once the land has gone that is gone if
it is not secured now connections
between the communities this is what I
think the board has raised and every
annual planner I've been involved in now
and I would say a big thank you to the
council and Amir for the efforts and
advocating for State Island one safety
improvements and the wood in bypass and
request that this rent be continued but
as part of those safety improvements
already been considered by NZTA the
board one counts on can work with them
on developing safe access but the
distance in cyclists at the Pegasus
about and between woody and and Pegasus
there has been a real noticeable
increase in the number and frequency of
cyclists and pedestrians on this very
short street to the state highway 1
between Pegasus and woody end um this
year has been actually particularly
extremely noticeable during lockdown
with less traffic but I personally
usually travel that route every day and
just about every day I had seen somebody
cycling along there or walking and even
pushing strollers along there there is
just not acceptable
there is going to be an X or something
is not done and we request that you do
means ETA on that one they do have some
land off that they have purchased from
way ravenswood which would be a
possibility for something also cycleways
and walkways have been left unconnected
for far too long in our area whilst we
await on safety improvements on state
hole-in-one so specifically connecting
the gel cream a tuck trail to the longer
along the path to would in school on
State Highway one there's got to be a
number one priority to provide safe
cycling and scootering or what E&B
children to get to and from school
others include the ring hero woody in
path which ends at Chenery Road the path
through copper beech to connect to the
Gladstone Road cycle way by a Petrie's
Road and then of course we have the
regular woody and path that just means
at chenery's Road we have been waiting
for these some projects to be all
connected up and it is just it is taking
some time community board budgets we
were asked to look at our budgets and so
we looked at the landscaping budget and
the board has agreed not to see any
landscaping budget for the coming year
from Council our board has twelve
thousand dollars in less year's budget
that we would like to carry over which
we can expend in the next financial year
we see this as important given their
priority from council is likely to be
given to infrastructure projects
to ensure that some of those smaller
local projects can happen cuz these have
have an amazing positive impact on
community in an example there is the
accessible beach access that Pegasus
Beach which is just been completed the
feedback from this small project has
been very positive and get a real lift
to people probably just the right time
as it showed that something that is
consider an important it's it's it's
getting on to their feet which for some
people they just have not been able to
do for some time so it's not that the
beach is more accessible to all and has
just given everybody a real lift going
toward discretionary funding the board
would like to signal that in the next
long-term plan we will be seeking an
increase in discretionary funding for
our community groups this is an
important one for our area because with
new communities thing established the
needs are very high to establish new
groups and give that sense of belonging
that we want to see in our community and
finally from us a big thank you to
council to start for the Amidah ship and
their responsiveness to the pandemic and
i'm here for any questions thanks shown
it's a very clear submission thank you
so first I have councillor Stewart
followed by counts that barn up with
some questions they mean Council Blakey
cancer Stewart first thank you and thank
you for your comprehensive submissions
Shona very well done and the sift and
public hall the total rebuild well
Newhall project is 1.3 million do you
know whether the Sifton public hall
committee or the community is able to
sustain a low interest or interest-free
loan that the council might like to
consider is one of the options to help
out was that project I haven't looked at
the financials lately and you know
things have changed going forward and
with this money you know
available through things like router and
things like that so that may have an
impact so really rather not say because
I really just do not have the knowledge
of that specifically counselor there any
other questions here Sandra thank you so
move to counts libecki yeah you're not
muted there L yeah you are now now your
mutual you're on mute
now we're right you're right now that
great bone of contention known as
Pegasus Lake you and I both know that
council green space specifically have
tried very hard over the years to get
some action have have you got any foot
any strong thoughts on a on a strategy
for us to to up the ante on the owners
which of course is not us
to get some progress on on on fixing the
thing the best opportunity possible the
new owners are called Templeton Growth
they have taken over unfortunately it's
been a bit of difficulty with lockdown
happening with the man able to engage
more with the community as they did want
to actually do and so I think this is
the idea opportunity to actually work
with the Templeton group use the
expertise that hopefully he can can can
bring to the table and actually try and
come up with a plan going going forward
just briefly Templeton group here meet
with me and they've met with Pegasus
residence group and they meet with a
keen and a certainly signaling in our
staff for willingness to try and work on
this so just I don't want to get into a
debate about it but just to let you know
that and they've been in contact so it's
encouraging at this point counts to the
bonus yes hello Shana and thanks for
your very full submission and my
question is your your board is
advocating to lower the rates increase
and and as much as we possibly can as
the the wooden Pegasus community are
prepared to accept a lower level of
service
in order for us to do that for example
not looking after trees so much preps
mowing of those sort of areas does your
board understand that by having to lower
rates we would have to lower service
potentially yes we are aware of that
there are some areas that we we wouldn't
want to see a decrease in service you
know we've just managed to hit some
areas around the community looking a bit
better I would also actually point out
that Pegasus itself does does actually
pay a service charge for maintenance of
street trees and reserves I understand
because we have a high number of
reserves so there is that sort of thing
I mean there is a balancing edge we do
actually have to if you don't maintain
the place the communities yeah
the long term it can actually cost more
money it also has an impact on that how
people feel about the community so that
is you know I don't in for you it's a
balancing it thank you any further
questions of colleagues is it you
indicating a question there Joan no so
just shiny you mentioned around the
discretionary fund then you were looking
to pay for that to be looked better than
the long-term plan any idea of what sort
of increase you might be thinking might
should be considered around the
discretionary fund community board has
actually worked quite hard over the past
few years to actually get their traction
and the community around the awareness
that that fund is actually the for the
in there has also been a bit of
discussion about whether we would look
at reviewing the criteria for the
discretionary fund to focus more on that
the local community groups thank you
thank you for cancer
Redmond thank you Oh Shona thank you for
your submission
you're aware of these circumstances work
over that the council finds itself in
are you able to prioritize any of your
point does the board have a view on
certain matters and priority you don't
have to prioritize them all but if you
have a key priority I'll be interested
to know well some don't actually have a
lot of cost initially like a you know
until the 6th and the whole committee
actually get that decision from the
community about that which way they want
to go there is actually very little cost
involved other than see staff time so
some of those actually have very very
you know cost involved pegasus lake is
actually a relatively similar one her
nearly staff type things like connecting
the gel creamer tough trail through the
wood ian skulk should not be a huge cost
project but the bit that has to be
filled and was actually already agreed
to be done between just at the end of
woody in vitro
I think it have been due to start in
April but we would actually like to see
the footpath on state highway 1 widened
to allow cyclists along there safely so
that they can actually get to would in
school safely using the footpath so that
one necessarily shouldn't think you'd
cost project actually think without you
know one of the big ones poses in a lot
of my a staff time I can come back to it
the NZTA routing NZTA on the on the path
between the pegasus roundabout and what
in is actually means ETA responsibility
so again at staff time and that is the
end of the footpath that woody end that
does need to be completed and the
argument has always been that on the
western side there is a drain there and
our response to that has always been
how about the eastern side there is no
dry because it would be safer for people
to cross in a 50k area and we there's
clear visibility in both ways then it is
for the back I think you've done a good
summary there Thank You Shona one final
question I think Sandra you indicated
yeah Sandra you're good to go
is it for me yeah you indicated you want
to ask what what this is a team achill
question about what's happening with our
system here today
it's periodically switching off the
speakers on our system and Joan can you
hear okay well I won't burden China with
us we've TM perhaps could just with in
look into that but hey look hey look can
we just hold on it because we've got a
bit of a gap between we'll deal with it
in a minute so that's showing us thank
you very much for the preparation of
this submit the board submission and
also your time today you've put your
case and your views very very succinctly
and we appreciate it
going forward the council will be
considering the annual plane 26 to 28 of
May and then we look to adopt it on the
16th of June and we'll be able to
communicate our decisions beyond then
I'm sure it'll probably be in the media
before then where we're likely to be but
we'd look at officially and
communicating at that point that we
appreciate your time and thank you for
presenting your board's view today nice
to see you - take care Cheers
Tiye just on the point that sandra
raised before we invite board chair jira
dan what's there is an issue with for
some with sound as there any any answer
on that Joan have you got the same view
to hit me I had to push my button about
every five seconds I hardly heard a word
of what Shona seed yeah I'm not
yeah I'm noticing that because I had the
issue a few meetings ago the speakers on
your system automatically flipping on
and off all the time so their arrow like
that on your taskbar at the bottom if
you press that you'll see the speaker
icon and it's gonna cross by it you need
to tap it and turn your speaker's back
on again and it's doing it all the time
tío Tina are you we are ordained are you
aware of any issues going on there I'm
not aware of any issues mr. mayor they
it's not resumed function so I don't
know if it's actually the iPads or the
hard way that the councils are using it
doesn't seem that all the counselors at
the same problems no I can hear I can
hear fine no just it was plugged in have
you got your power cord into your device
because it sometimes it turns my own
well just just a matter of things
there's only so many things that staff
can rectify here but it is all recorded
so we'll make sure that a link is sent
out to you worth it on if you want to
review it afterwards but apologies if
there are issues going on but there are
only so many things we can resolve
through this time if it's a connection
issue that's something the council can't
immediately resolve but appreciate the
difficulty some are experiencing Joan my
difficulty was only when Shona was
talking when the council counselor were
talking it wasn't an issue was only when
Jonah was talking okay well I think
we're going to move along now we've been
advised by staff from the Pacific if
there's no issue but we those recorded
and make sure a copy
in debt to you and there will be minutes
of this as well okay
alright so um tear is some porch here
Jim juror than the waiting room yes mr.
mayor just let him in thank you
hello Jim can you hear us Jim Jim Jared
hello Jim
Jim can you hear us
Jim porch here to it we can hear you oh
he's connecting to audio now here we are
can you hear us now Jim he's on mute can
you unmute just some of that mute Jim
you like Dunedin Council you're gonna
stand out so we can see you've got pants
honestly yeah no I'm not and I'm
certainly not encouraging you to either
knowing or cheekiness so firstly can we
welcome you to a hearing this afternoon
you've got up to 10 minutes that
includes questions so consider the board
so that members have read this at the
board submission but City welcome you to
highlight your main points Thank You mr.
and well the community board appreciates
the position the council room and
totally agrees with the position you're
now taking to review you your your
budgets and especially with the effect
rates will have on businesses
particularly those struggling in our
community and I fear that it's likely to
be fairly serious so the board is
appreciative of the fact that the
council are doing the work that they're
doing and our submission is pretty small
in shorts that won't take me too long
the board agrees that cuts unnecessary
in the budget and the lowering of rates
and we're also conscious of the fact and
we're not suggesting that you have a new
rate increase because that can have
quite major negative effects have you
put off important work for later date
and it was observed by some members of
the board that it's important for our
local contractors and local business
also to have some work and keep going so
what the board is suggesting is that you
attempt to achieve the lowest possible
rate increase we stress the lowest
possible but not necessarily and no we
leave that to you to achieve what you
think's in the businesses of the
district we have suggested that the
council should stop all non-essential
spending that's this year that's not
absolutely necessary and we've cited in
our comments that the council building
for example we think is aboard that's
something that doesn't have to happen
now
it can happen next year or later we've
also commented for example about the
park-and-ride the major expenses they're
clearly as a result of the virus
economic activity is going to be
tragically reduced somewhat and the need
for transportation and food bus service
that he can were visiting the board
doesn't see that as necessary at this
stage and in fact we would doubt that
there will be much of any increase the
patronage that means to our way of
thinking from the regular board's
perspective in our community we've got
three three sites we've got the white
street site that obviously is very
adequate now and could certainly
continue to serve we've got the River
Road site by the just down the road from
polls that's obviously capable the short
term of catering and then you've got
South Park where some workers you know
mr. mee has been done there and I think
that that could probably be fine there
we've also commented that on other areas
of the budget where you've got some very
substantial budgets particularly around
say drainage for example I'm quite sure
you in your wisdom would find there
you wouldn't be putting communities at
risk if non-essential non-urgent
drainage was spread out a little bit so
really that's the base of the board's
input we are very conscious of the work
the council was doing the board's very
happy with the communications we've had
both with staff yourself the CEO and the
finance manager who participated in some
board meetings I can't say I think the
Xoom meetings haven't been as good as I
would like them to have been as far as a
board attendance is gone but that's a
matter for us and not a mess for you for
you to determine but we've appreciated
the communications from council from
staff from yourself as we all struggle
forward and the board really just says
to you we trust you totally on this
we're all in the same same kettle you
might say together we all want the same
outcome and so we made these few
suggestions and we just leave it to you
mr. Meanor they won't get us to be so
trusting always think thank you Jim
appreciate
yes the same submission and the point
you've made I'm just first question for
me around the landscape budget for the
board to do have a view sorry I thought
you'd already got hold of there yes the
board has discussed it at length and
we've discussed it again and resume
meeting the other night we think that we
are fine at the moment with what we've
got we haven't speed the Shia's budget
there's only two months left we are
prepared to have a new budget for
landscaping for the next financial year
sorry I should have mentioned it that's
okay
thank you now even if you don't want to
we won't grizzle well thank you for that
position is there any questions of
members other councillors no no it's
good to see you all looking so happy in
June yeah thank you Jim we do have a
couple of questions for you and that's
probably what we'll have time for so it
so can you just indicate the hands again
who were there the Kirsten no cares
about that and I think it was councillor
duty is that Creek you so fiercely
counts the banner
thank you Thank You mr. Jared we can't
let you go without asking you at least
one question so I know one from you ago
I got to be traditional and very quickly
just obviously trying to keep rates as
low as possible may mean we have to
slightly lower some levels of service
for the short term do you have any view
on how that your boards area would feel
about that
no they would agree with that I mean if
you're going to cut some costs you're
going to have to lower services that
let's take him it's how you go about it
and I can remember wind in another life
we had to find cuts of three percent
across the board every department was
asked to bring forward three percent on
the basis that wouldn't kill the economy
but just along the lines it would be
lowering the services I would expect
that of you thank you
cassadee question I was going to ask as
well okay all right say it was a good
report Wendy sorry I'm pulling it he is
it is it is there any other questions of
members thank you I think you've given a
very clear submission the adjourn so
just to let you know as you'll know from
past experience we'll be considering
this 26 to 28 sub mates will be
considering the submissions in
deliberating on those and then we'll be
looking at adopting area in your pain on
the 16th of June so we'll certainly
communicate counsels decisions I'm
following this it just you go well and I
hope Murray's doing okay by the way I
understand she's here little operations
I hope she's doing all right
heaven heard today so thank you for that
and I just wish you all the best in your
deliberations we're all in this together
so good luck thanks Jim thank you very
much to you is is Kristin the whiting
word yes mr. mayor just get it in thank
you
hi Chris welcome welcome to our annual
plain hearings and thank you for being
present so firstly you can you hear us
okay
in perhaps you might just want to unmute
can you hear okay thank you so so just
first so firstly so you can hear us all
right
there's a key now so we've got you have
14 minutes which includes questions so
we're in your hands
thank you thank you very much mister Mia
there's a feedback via some well I'm not
sure what that feedbacks from it is one
of your staff able to help dear yes
getting questions of mine from some time
ago two years to it we're doing this
there any reason why there's that
feedback there it's someone got the
YouTube open there in the background
have you got the YouTube thing really if
you close the YouTube Chris there's a
delay in the YouTube I can still hear
you so we can still hear the feedback
but they look give it a go we've got ten
minutes we'll see how we go and it's
being recorded than any we're ahead of
time anyway so okay if you've got
YouTube off now
Chris alright can you hear us I can hear
you but I can't see you okay okay well
we can hear you fine so you happy with
it we'll just proceed and okay so a
Chris teen after ten minutes with
questions included so we've seen your
submission so consider that's been read
in just if you want to speak to your
points to the earth it would be great
thank you thank you very much mister Mia
and counselors and staff members for
giving us this opportunity I we kept our
submission well we didn't actually even
put in the submission we just
acknowledge that there was an
opportunity to submit with their
requests and wants and desires but
because of the situation we actually
chose not to we know there's quite a
negative financial impact event because
of climate 19 that cancels are going to
have to deal with and cope with them the
best possible way and it probably our
main request was that you keep the rates
as long as possible not reduce them not
to keep them at the same level we know
they've got to be increased and we hope
and a smaller smallest capacity that it
possibly can now I don't know how you're
going to do that but I wish you all the
Beast but I think at this stage from our
community's point of view we need to
look after our residents wants and
desires can be put on the back burner
for a while
and we've been we're fortunate that we
are once are often things that have just
got to be put up in the community like
the Ovilus submit that would really
really like to have up what up as soon
as possible but it's already on there on
the cards and we've got
some landscaping money that we'll be
able to run use for other things that we
may want so really I just wish you all
the very best for the next 12 months
working in the best possible way for our
business business people and our
residents thank you thank you Chris for
those comments very succinct submission
thank you for this question
I'll just ask you as around the board's
discretionary grant for landscaping is
does the board give an opinion on
whether or not you'd like then and that
the standard increase to occur this year
or were you looking to hold that other
boards have expressed an opinion as I
submitted to us today are you talking
about a dream statement just just the
landscape budget thank you
so our landscaping budget we've chosen
not to exceed any or ask for any more
funding to put towards it we will keep
that as the 2020 one year okay thanks
Chris
councillor duty you are indicating a
question said that no is there any other
questions officially so a councillor
Ward followed by counts department
councillor Ward mine is not actually a
Christian it's just to say thank you so
much Chris for everything you do for us
and won't make a very excuse me you're
an amazing lady and we appreciate
everything you do from big thank you
counts the ward that I just would
appreciate if colleagues did keep it to
questions otherwise it'll be a bit of a
free-for-all but I think it's a
sentiment that's broadly shared by all
but I'll eat you away with at this time
councillor van it is thank you Chris my
question is we have had another
submitter seduced that one way to defer
some costs in the budget would be to
defer some of the regeneration projects
that we've got over the next few years
do you have any commentary from a board
pointed point of view yes
how you think the council should proceed
under the covert 19 situation with the
regeneration work I don't think I can
comment from the board boards point of
view it would have to be from a personal
point of view and and saying that I'm
sure the board will agree we don't have
to rush with anything you know there's
lots and lots of plans out there but I
think there's some other things and the
district that need to be done that are
more important then us rushing to get
things done and Clara with the region
money I'd like to think that the region
money doesn't disappear okay thank you
any further questions thank you thank
you Chris oh sorry
Kassar Edmond thank you Chris whoops oh
I am unmute you are thank you for your
Lita Chris we have a link the submission
from a board member I take it that your
board discussed a number of detailed
projects and decided as a board that the
economic well-being of the community
took precedence over specific projects
yes I would I was actually going to
bring that out that there are some can I
bring that up now
yes mr. Muir yes you can I was going to
make comment before I finished today
that I'm aware there are two more
submissions from community board members
which I need to really make clear that
they're not via mr. veer for may have a
point point of order point of order is
that those submissions are personal from
personal personal people who are members
of the board they are nothing to do with
the community which is for your question
yeah okay so the I think the points been
made that they are individual members
and certain
another view of the board the boards
made its submission so don't don't don't
require any further comment but thank
you yeah okay any other question the
accounts the Redmond no that's all okay
all right
okay thank you Chris for you I don't see
any other questions thank you Chris for
your succinct said mission in obviously
issue acknowledged we're in difficult
times so we appreciate the support of
the board and and what you've said just
going forward council will be
considering submissions deliberating on
those the 26th the 28th of May and we'll
look at adopting air in your clean on
the 16th of June so we'll communicate
our decisions with the board and the
community at that time so thank you
again for your time and we appreciate
the effort that the boards put into
Andrew have and presenting today thank
you
all right everyone we've got a well a
15-minute break let's call that a
10-minute break and then we could if
Martin's here we can just keep making
time which I think would be good so if
we could just resume it at 2:05 then in
the interim does the video go on
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to here
so I understand we have math and Peng
come with us as it create Martin rehips
a you you're a mutineer hello Martin
I even Martin try again our baton mass
and mass and were the wine you're under
MacAlpine so that's why I was wondering
so that's ok hey so thanks Martin you're
presenting on behalf of obviously carboy
promotions so you've got up to 10
minutes Martin they includes questions
so just assume that colleagues have read
your submissions so just either
summarized it but you can use the whole
time or if you want to or use the least
amount e and there'll be an opportunity
for questions that we're in your hands
thank you and welcome Thank You mr. Mia
and hello I as you see from Ed
submission there is actually not a lot
to talk to say on this kind of very
quickly go through the highlights we've
got a slide show which hopefully you're
all seeing on this few screens now yes
we are cool ok so weird the submissions
on two parts the first part is around
cycle web development around cowboy and
the kp8 strongly supports a proposal to
provide $250,000 in the recreation
budget towards the construction of a
recreation cycle route from the north
end of the Wine Library River Bridge to
central KY POI utilizing the existing it
can stop inks the recent KP a brand work
iPod brand workshop concluded that
walking and cycling is a key attraction
for visitors to carpool and that the
residents of North Christchurch are the
prime
target for visitors as the country
emerges from the cat lockdown it is
clear that domestic visitors carpool
will be key to ensuring that a wide
range of businesses in the kite Way area
survive now the as you can see on the
slide there the cnc project has already
made provision for the skeevers the link
and the design of its cycle way as shown
on the drawing in addition to their II
can is very supportive of the project as
it is complementary to its existing
recreational cycle trails and has
offered to complete some works to
facilitate the project and we just got a
very quick video here of for those that
haven't had taken a run along the track
this is a very quick summary of
[Music]
besides you can say that was a quick
run-through of the track I'm not sure
what you saw what I saw is a track
that's got already possible yes if
you're on a mountain bike that has some
real appeal if you improve the surface
for walkers who are trying to use the
track and as you saw there was a pram
struggling along the path there at one
point so as I said just to summarize we
have very much in support of this money
being pushed into the recreation budget
Part B of our submission is around the
walking and cycling maps and the KPA
wishes to acknowledge the great we're
again taken by EMC and promoting the
district through the visit Waimakariri
with website and visitor center and
encouraging visitors to use the mini
recreational facilities in the won their
career district the KP Ahead's KP has
worked with EMC and updating the
district
why'd walking and cycling guides that
will be published shortly
however the visit one rectory regard can
only provide a general overview and is
focused on highlighting the key cycle
written trials and the linkages between
the trails due to its general nature it
is not able to provide a detailed guide
to each of the routes and provide
historical cultural and recreational
information for visitors since era bring
workshops I see the KPA has undertaken
further research on what other areas
have done and concluded that the
approach taken by the Nelson region
would work well and card for the Nelson
area has created a series of walking and
cycling route maps and an a4 format some
single and some double-sided you'll see
examples of these four over page in a
submission these maps have a consistent
theme and have a schematic
easy-to-follow met commentary on points
of local cultural historic civic and
ecological interest and recreational
features the KPA is requesting a one-off
granted $15,000 to create 15 maps of the
cowboy the pine speech kuraki into Healy
area including providing the following
project management consultation with key
stakeholders including night I go to
harira manga co-op with historic
Association card point to a hearing
community board and en se it would have
a production of a digital version of the
maps and production of 500 hard copies
the distribution of digital copies to
EMC and other interested parties and
hosting other digital maps on the KPA
website as I say with the rest man
examples to the back of their submission
of two of the Nelson Max and Shawn and
Nelson have also got an app called the
now snake which provides access to these
links and it just so happens a widen a
career it has a similar technology
fix it so I'm open to any questions
Thank You thanks thanks Matt and could
we get out of the you so I can see all
colleagues here we able to accept thank
you
so we've got time for one probably one
quick question who would like to ask a
question castrate cancer thank you
mister we it Maddon just on the
distribution of the the maps you're
looking at a QR code type system on
these maps or are you looking at a
special app download or are you looking
at distributing I think hard copies
first at the eyesight service center
where we can have distribution points
there is of course the KPA website which
has we'll be able to host the digital
downloads there are other digital
opportunities as I say the why make app
is now available in one McCreery so it
may be that that can be spoken that can
be included in the equation we're still
in the early stages of working on this
process and how to be distributed that
there are a number of options thanks
Matt and I could probably allow one
through the question counselor reidman
do you hate your hand up just for tire
it's only not alluring it's just time so
Katherine do you think Thank You mr. mr.
Mia Martha no I think the the MEP idea
looks quite exciting presumably the KPA
would have ownership of the Macs and
give them away freely would that be the
intention yeah I don't know if the
ownership could be the right tune
because obviously they're going to be
produced and essentially it's as soon as
it produced there's no value in them so
as necess its ownership even relevant we
will be covering we will be managing the
distribution creation process if you and
here's ownership we've just lost you the
imagine yeah we just lost you losing you
the your buffering so sorry
we must your point so anyway we will I
think you answer the hernia bent around
the ownership so thank you madam just
while you are with us just think if you
submission just to let you know that
consideration of the annual plan by
counsel deliberations 26 to 28 of May
and will look to adopt air in your clean
on the 16th of June and we will
obviously communicating our decisions
and to you in the community at following
it so thank you for your submission and
thank you for the work that you do with
kPa and we appreciate the submission
this afternoon thank you thank you okay
the next if we got carp we east
residents group and the waiting room
leads here yes we do mister may have
just lived him in his place
thank you hello
it looks like Michelle hi Michelle
welcome can you hear us
all right you're fine to me you're fine
to be on mute because I'm going to get
you to present your submission if you're
ready you're Iying okay well Michelle
welcome on behalf of the council to you
this afternoon
you've got up and you're obviously
representing car police resident group
Association you've got up to ten minutes
and cluding questions so consider your
submission as read and we welcome
hearing the points that like to make
thank you thank you me and thank you
counselors for giving the east residents
association the attainment allotment
we've given quite a few submissions they
were condensed by your team and you have
we've taken them as read I'd like to
start off with the car parking and
kayakoy which is proposed to go next to
the new world one of the we believe this
is an ideal place we are concerned that
the money that was not what forward by
the businesses did not as somewhere or
may not have made it into the council
caucus we would like an investigation
into where that money is in an
accountability on why it wasn't provided
the land next door itself has actually
got mature trees and we would actually
believe using these trees as an
enhancement instead of actually if you
did go through with the car parking
facility not making at a tar seal comic
but actually use the trees as a feature
so when you come into the area it
actually moves into a flow-on effect
with the red zone regeneration projects
that have been used and and keeping we
also made a submission where was what
the community hub and welcome back going
forward we also would like to pass
comment on freedom camping in the
hi boy regeneration areas I am we would
like to put forward that they can
counsel and set up actually having a
bylaw we are freedom camping is illegal
and people are encouraged to use our
camping ground facilities now the reason
for this is a provides a more tidy area
we have had a serial freedom camp in the
kayak we East regeneration area if you
put the direct these people into our
camping grounds we are providing revenue
for a business we're providing
employment for our locals and we're
keeping our amenities in a state where
they're welcoming for visitors to come
and wander not camp and state especially
if they are and camper vans or just fans
that are not actually got sentry such a
you know senator II provide you know
what I'm saying so we would actually
like to really see that as a bylaw and
provide support to the camping ground
businesses in the district my next topic
is the Clio koi East spraying practices
now for those who haven't been to the
Kai point III generation zone recently
in really some other of 2019 an
extensive severe spraying program was
taken in this area and what it has done
has actually impacted on mature trees
that have survived being the earthquakes
the demolition and were earmarked by
Sarah we have lost natives we have lost
magnolias these are trees that were
beautiful trees to walk around but also
it impacted on the skinks and geckos
that were reestablishing themselves and
what I'll call this grassland area and
my skin's and eco geckos are protected
by doc so we've actually got an
ecosystem that was a
impacted by a very strong spray campaign
to top it off the dead weeds that were
left in the tree lines are still there
so they're a fire hazard so you could
argue that they were going to be used to
stop a fire hazard but we've got a whole
lot of dead weeds sitting there and it
doesn't look pretty
now given the coded lockdown area for
the High Point East became quite an area
for people to wander because it's a
grassland it's not a manicured area but
it's just nice if you want to go and
have that wander be therapeutic and just
unwinding because the space is via
innocent good acid if we actually make
it look neglected by the overzealous
spraying and the plants that have
actually or trees that are damaged or
dying we're actually creating a negative
impact to our community at a time when
they do need positive well-being and
using this area as another well burying
place for kind residents North
Canterbury residents but also for
residents from Christchurch to come tome
the whole red zone area would actually
be a day-trippers asset to our community
if you take last Sunday when they after
the lockdown you had numerous cars going
into Sumner
why don't we promote the kuiper
regeneration area as the alternative and
this is something that could be in
support of what Martin the previous
speaker has done there it's not we've
got to promote the kayakoy regeneration
area is the well-being area that you can
walk you've got access to everything and
draw it and you can do it cheaply and
support the businesses by promoting that
we then move on to the licence to occupy
if the council's going to be fiscally
responsible then if someone's being
issued a license to occupy they should
actually be charged a price if you look
at our lens and survey or any other
councils when they're issuing the
license people have to pay for it the
one I'm referring to it was the one just
recently issued to the port an eagle if
I was in London and had a cafe by the
teams or if I was in Paris and had a
cafe by the sign
I would not be getting a license to
occupy for free
I'd be paying quietly is the Riviera of
and this is a beautiful asset death has
now been given to one business a
priesthood a precedence has been seen if
another business wants to use the site a
similar area are you going to charge him
were you going to make it free if you
take the same argument he is equates to
business residence well he got something
extended his lane for free why can't I
so I think the council going forward
needs to be very careful and mindful
that a pristine can be said which is
very hard to backtrack but also it
generates revenue and adds value
if someone something has a monetary
value to it people value it we would
then like to talk to our next point is
absolute you know you've got two minutes
Michele yep has anyone got any questions
so you have you got any through the
point you either make or you here before
questions yeah I'll take a questions
okay so any questions of colleagues it
doesn't appear to be so you're welcome
to you can conclude your remarks or if
we can leave early just I think
everyone's well I certainly have and I'm
sure others hip as well they've read
your submissions so understand the point
you've made yeah just the one around the
budgeting for the regeneration area
personally I believe we should actually
continue with the regeneration projects
that we've got that we need to have
accountability around what where it's
being spent so
just be financially prudent okay thank
you
Thank You Michelle you've made your
points really well there's a question
from councillor Edmund so caserita and
hello I'll be quick Michelle you're
running out of time has the residents
Association thought about the effect of
Cove vat19 on council budgets and will a
hip ever view yes we actually have
thought about the impact on code of cove
at 19 we believe the budgets should
either be held at where they are I don't
we don't believe they should be
decreased because we still have to
continue to maintain our asset we also
need to be forward-thinking that to
bring people into our district we need
to have a gateway and you need to have
somewhere where it's welcoming and Kai
poi is that gateway to the Waimakariri
in the redzone investment area would be
manager negligible when you consider
that there is already budget there that
community will councillor hadn't Chris
Greengrass had mentioned so the kuiper
regeneration area is nearly there why
stop now because you've spent 90% of or
you know a large portion of it do the
other team percent and then let it set
and bring and promote the people to come
to use it as a day trippers paradise
that is cheap it's family orientated
it's covers all ages and abilities
it is our jewel and the s it that we
need to promote full kai port in the
wider district thanks Michelle Thank You
Michelle unfortunately you've run out of
time but just we appreciate the points
that you've made just so you're aware of
our process between council will
deliberate on submissions between the 26
to the 28th of may we all have been
adopting the annual plan on the 16th of
June and then we'll be in a position to
communicate our decision
at a point after this but thank you for
your time and we appreciate you and the
carpel yeast residents association the
time you put into your submission so
thank you
Thank You cancellous thank you thank you
dear
we got carp we residents group in the
waiting room no yes we do well you're um
you're on you're not on mute you see
might just want to think about that one
we up to the Pegasus reason scream yeah
that's right Pegasus residence group so
we've got looks like we've got Roger the
three hours we've got this afternoon so
welcome to Roger Rhonda and Rennell on
behalf of Pegasus resonance group you've
got up to ten minutes to present firstly
can I just check that your who's
presenting on your behalf today yes
darling okay so you've got ten minutes
including questions we're on a bit of a
tight timeframe because of others that
are in the waiting area as well so look
let you start the Rhondda and hand over
to whomever perhaps we should tear just
unmute sheer Roger and Rennell so that
there's a bit of a free flow via and at
this time permitting we'll ask questions
within their ten minutes thanks Rhonda
to present today on behalf of the penis
residence group basically we actually
want to acknowledge the trying
conditions recently to say thank you for
the multitude of work that we've noticed
taking place on condition started last
week we know also that one of the items
on in submission regarding beach access
is currently being dealt with which is
really great to see has got a really
good response from from their residence
that's great so today I'm here with
Roger
and run our statements to talk to you
about Pegasus and where we believe it's
current priorities I the playing field
has changed quite a bit since we last
spoke to URI the change of ownership
from Todd property to Templeton group
opens up opportunities both PID inw DC
that didn't exist volatile property
we're at the helm and let's make no
bones about the fact that Todd property
were a significant obstacle when it came
to improvements and water quality of the
lake and using the lake and proposed
reserve beside the swing bridge be
student council we had a meeting with
Templeton group representatives and II
came back in February and a very
optimistic that a fresh collective
approach from Council we can and tipple
the group will lead to improvements in
lake quality that in turn will lead to a
lake that can be vested in council
without being an unnecessary burden to
great Pires
which is what we all want to see
everything so it's mostly most of you
have heard from us before a new
purpose-built community center for
Peters a huge priority for the penises
community we love our temporary facility
and the new spaces opened late last year
been very well utilized then enable many
of you connections to be made
we are certainly moving at under the
lockdown conditions as they
approximately 20 volunteers we will help
who were helping to run the center we've
talked to you on multiple occasions
about the reasons for peer support
center at Pegasus and this is a
completely separate project in
requirement from the plan to every
service center at the bravest would
commercial health so Pegasus now has a
population of approximately 3,000 350
and that's based on up-to-date building
consent first and we've been waiting for
over 11 years for a community facility
building conceit figures also tell us
the region
if the capital capital expenditure we
see included an annual plans long and
short-term keeps going to run your own
car quit so we remind you that the
current list community facility and
Pegasus does not meet the recommended
standard adopted by council in July 2018
regarding population size based of
meeting requirements we expect to see a
meanwhile we ask the council entered
into discussions with timbering to
ensure that vesting of the proposed
preserve beside the lake swingbridge and
a plan showing the location of that
reserve was emailed to you all yesterday
I hope yes
so Roger have you got some follow-up on
that
yeah well I contacted it or try to
contact
Templeton's this morning and they're
going to get back to me later this
afternoon about where they're at with
the vesting of the land Council I mean
you'll be aware that like as Rhonda said
then under Todd's they were reluctant to
do it and this council took over the
lake and then they would do the land
that they're investing at the same time
so we came this year to really break the
impasse and really get that blend in to
the council so that we can then focus on
you know getting this facility up and
running and working with Council and
others to make sure that happens so
that's our main priority this year
really is to push that along so yeah I
think Rhonda you summed it up pretty
well and not a lot more I can really add
to that yeah so that's where that's
where we're coming from thank you
this Seri Reynold do you want to add any
points or is at the end of your
submission Rhonda we're happy to take
questions okay all right okay so I'm
questions from colleagues can't see any
at this point now
intro so doesn't look like there's any
questions from colleagues I think you've
made your points really well no very
succinctly port neighs you said you've
made them before so the council's are we
were them and in the work got on going
with Templeton as you usually write the
absurd so thank you is there any
concluding and just to add on as a
research group we get a lot of flack
from locals from people living here
saying you know when is something going
to be done because someone will get
killed there one day so that's that's a
real concern for us as well I just took
Thank You Cal so Duty you had a question
you're on mute Wendy right Duren thank
you thank you very much for your
submission I just want to ask you with
your round about what is your preferred
so moving forward to how to fix the
thing so we can be a windy it's a really
tricky fix and we've been in loads of
discussions it's just it's really hard
it may be the traffic lights that's come
up a few times so it isn't easy
obviously one really quick thing that
they could do
the speed limit is currently 70 and it
when they put out the price of last year
for I mean it's fabulous they propose to
leave it at 70 which is just ludicrous
sorry you know there's one simple thing
that could be done there that they
haven't sort of done - yeah it's not
easy there's a lot of things to be taken
into consideration but that's not a
reason to do nothing thank you thank you
and your points are well made and and
certainly there's support from the
council and respect to up there as well
and as you know we've been advocating
for improvements the year so look you've
probably heard this so council will be
considering their annual clean we're
deliberating on it but on between the
26th to the 28th of May we're looking to
adopt dairy in your plan around that
will be on the 16th of June and then
we'll be in a position to communicate
our decisions at that point that thank
you to the Pegasus reason its
association for your presentation to
Rhonda Roger and ra'nell thank you for
all that you do on behalf of your
community you're very stride wickets and
they're lucky to have you in the
position that you're on say thank you go
well Cheers bye-bye right team we've got
a break for 11 minutes so grab yourself
a cup of tea Dean's got the samples
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back everyone to the
hearing tear I understand that we're
just waiting on mr. Pinkham but we have
mr. Kean's is that correct that is
correct mr. mayor so if you could see if
mr. qian's is ready to make us some
presenter submission thank you good
afternoon Brent can you hear us you're
on mute Dias you might just want to
unmute you're still on mute - here it
goes
hi Breen good afternoon good afternoon
Steve got 10 minutes and thank you for
being available ahead of time so if
you'd like to present your submission
you've been up to 10 minutes including
questions so from colleagues so I'll
leave you to make a submission points
Thank You mr. Muir I've decided to throw
together a PowerPoint presentation based
on previous issues that other submitters
head so you should have a shared screen
boy now it's not working here we go I
wanted to start off with the first with
the library libraries pulling around
about 10,000 people every day every week
with an hour way many libraries and any
business would know that if you get
10,000 people through your front doors
in any week they'd be most impressed
interestingly enough libraries only pull
in $200,000 for the coffers I believe
that some of these issues need to be
dealt with in terms of some of the fees
like for instance rate payers paid more
than 185 dollars a year for libraries
and museums yet a non-resident can pay
for a library card and only pay have to
pay $70 for six months library should
provide fees or services for free I
don't disagree with that but I think
that some of the offering has gone a
little bit too far in terms of providing
free services like for instance
virtually every time you go into
you see the computers are being used all
of those computer usages are for free
yet it's not for free it's the actual
rate payers that are paying for it if
you were to compare costs or the
services that are equivalent in
christchurch libraries you'll find that
our local libraries are actually a third
of the equivalent services so simply put
I believe that you should look at
commercialize some of the elements of
the libraries to reduce the burden
moving quickly on to 112 elder Pearson
units very valued at 14 million and it's
great that the current rental covers
costs if you were to look at what is
happening in other areas Tarun
Wellington and Christchurch they've
actually changed to herself social
housing ownership model and that's to
take advantage of the government
subsidies effectively what would happen
if you were to change it to a charitable
trust
so councils don't have ownership but
it's a character a charitable trust
you'd actually have no impact on tenants
and what they paid and in fact if you
went with a income related model you
would actually have some tenants
actually paying less but in terms of
what the council receive they would be
actually topped up to market value rent
which would increase the income
considerably currently there's over 20
families living in motels within this
district because there's no emergency
housing this is a real issue so and also
if you were to look at the current
rental versus what is the market rental
in the way Macready its considerable so
I believe that the change of ownership
model ship would be fiscal fiscally
responsible plus also all the extra
money and I worked it out that you'd
probably end up getting additional
income of about a million dollars for
the council moving on the promotion of
the district the why McCrory district
council spend over seven hundred
thousand dollars a year on promotions
and economic development and if you to
break it down by promotions Association
Oxford promotions this is the list of
all things that they do with an Oxford
they do a huge amout of work
in their community to bring people into
the town plus also for events and that
sort of thing
they are certainly doing a wonderful job
if you look at ring your promotions for
31,000 that the why make council provide
Plus also the Christmas event again they
do a lot of work within the community
bring a lot of people with them into the
town and they also receive large
sponsorship donations as well if you
were to look at the higher point
promotions they actually get the largest
chunk of money $32,000 yet they hold no
events that attract visitors into the
town and as I said earlier local event
sexier vibrant they actually bring
people into the town they make it a
really interesting place to actually
come and visit they encourage local
talent social culture and economic
benefit so hence the reason why we
should have more and more events in and
around the towns and promotions if you
to look at Enterprise North Canterbury
and if this is a snapshot the the text
at the bottom of the screen it'd be
audited and risk committee meeting on
the 19th and then November they said
that attracting more visitors who spend
more and stay longer provides economic
benefits NC are proud of their
commitment to showcasing and promoting
the opportunities of this wonderful
district to visitors business and local
residents and also they promote the
region as a visitor destination however
if you were to look at the actual into
their website like for instance kya poi
these are the number of kyotofu
businesses or eateries that they promote
there's only three when in fact there's
over 50 rhaenyra there's only five being
promoted deal and this considerably more
than that so I start wondering is too is
this really going to attract more
visitors to spend more and stay longer
when there's only small amount of
businesses being closed I then did an
analysis a an online analysis of various
different districts as to how each of
the districts are doing with regard to
their websites so as I could look
visit why mercury website and compared
against outpost Southland and Queenstown
and you probably can't see that very
well so I've just highlighted it there
oh sorry visit waymaker he actually
ranks one of the lowest 3,000 visitors
per month into their website visit by
macro the interesting one to look at is
this one here the bounce rate 81% bounce
rate which means it out of the three
thousand six hundred visitors two
thousand nine hundred and thirty three
of them don't interact with the website
they actually just bounce straight out
if you were to look at the domestic to
respond anybody want to have a guess at
how much why make percentages third of
one percent so we could do lots better
in terms of promoting the district if
you were to go back to 2018 the March
21st Emma
Dangerfield did or did a article on a
ANC and that sort of thing in terms of
promotional effectiveness in the
waymaker II and there's a whole pile of
quotations likes of Kirsten said that
what's their been for the back for the
ratepayers
acoustic councillor Stewart said that
she was less than comfortable with the
status quo yeah there was a lot of
issues raised with regard to the
promotion of the district and nothing
seems to really have changed also if you
were to look at that it actually said in
the newspaper article that three hundred
eighty thousand dollars a year was paid
by the council but in fact in fact it's
six hundred and thirty thousand dollars
if you were to look at other destination
marketing from the other districts
you'll find that one thing that stands
out and that is that the others seem to
do far better than the why Makka reading
and it's mainly because the businesses
that are included in their websites the
ones that are paying rates in rent do
not are actually put into their website
whereas the visit Rome acreage website
you actually have to pay so effectively
they're double dipping
the council are paying them to promote
the district and they have made a
commitment to promote the district
however
yeah the actual ratepayers already
paying 6% in the green different music
you know you've got approximately two
minutes left
yep keeping an eye thank you so I
believe that we're under selling the
district and under-delivering I think
that destination marketing is
economically important for a large
proportion of the district of the
businesses in the district so I think
it's sort of almost like knocking all
the blocks over and starting afresh
really develop a district-wide marketing
plan look at all of the players instead
of them all working in silos and
actually seeing how we can all work
together to actually make this two-bits
district clicks you come and visit so
thank you very much I think you're doing
a wonderful job the council staff and
the counselors really that's about it
from me thinking eggs Breen thank you
for your submission just probably got
time for one quick question the council
Williams you great for the young isn't
patient you had one major thing in part
or you want to be promoted be it is
higher poi as New Zealand's best River
town and effectively that's what we need
to focus on in terms of River town and
you center around the river town but as
you saw from the previous submitters the
likes of Martin Martin cook it is
walking and I've created a website
called carp or new zealand calm and we
actually got local residents to put in
as to what their top tips is what doing
Clark would and walking cycling visiting
the lakes visiting the river there's so
many things to do inquiry and it's a
matter of marketing it better but I
think coordinating it from a central
position so effectively looking at the
$700,000 that is currently being spent
by the council and looking at how we can
leverage that and all working together
to actually make it the best for the
whole of the district as opposed to
operating in various different silos hey
thanks for well thank you bring for your
submission you you um
so PowerPoint you able to send a copy of
it to us so we've got a that would be
appreciated think you had some good
points on the other obviously like to
reflect on well thank you for your
submission just for your information the
26 between the 26th and the 28th of May
council will be deliberating on the
annual plane and then we expect to adopt
that on the 16th of June and then we'll
be in the position to communique do
thinking after this so thank you for
your your thoughts we appreciate the
time you take and then go well thank you
thank you Nick Easter's Martin Pinker
miss Martin than the waiting were in the
area unfortunately not mr. May he's
still struggling to join us but Richard
is yeah ok well let's move on with
Richard so Richards presentation was
updated and to the our picks last night
so we'll this morning so hope you've all
got those hello Richard I just see
you're connecting he's connecting to
audio Richard can you hear us
you're connected now Richard perhaps if
can you hear us okay no yeah there we
are
can you hear us okay there Richard hello
Richard no this seems to be a bit of an
issue here Richard can you hear us at
all perhaps tear you might just want it
if you've got Richards number give
Richard a call are there we are there we
go hello Richard hi Dan how are you good
good to see you thank you for thank you
for being being early and so we're in
the position to hear you now so we've
received your submission thank you and
so well up to ten minutes to make your
points and if you would like that
includes questions if you'd like to
leave some time for questions that's up
to you some colleagues may have some
questions the essay in your hands for
next 10 minutes very good thank you very
much yeah theof the council's got
opportunity to view the PowerPoint
presentation in a sec through I suit me
here particularly one photo yes okay is
that gonna be on screen is it
I think it's within their submission
pics if we say colleagues have got a
copy of its 13.1 okay so it does
included the yeah all right very good
I'll get underway then that first of all
thank you very much for the opportunity
to put forward our submission to the
annual plant and just want to give a
little bit of a brief background on the
mental Sports Club it's obviously if
you're looking at slide to deer its
reserve of over 80 hectares in size and
its home to 13 sports clubs and does
also host other have been such as touch
the muddy good run Judith lawns and
other community events as well over the
past ten years the the local community
is obviously grown significantly and and
we are very proud to be with women
councilman providing a significant
recreation and leisure area for the
surrounding part now looking at slide
three manual sports flow continually
working to that towards maintaining
improving the facilities reserved to
encourage people to be active in their
lifestyles
whether it be in sport or sport and
leisure or their own personal leisure
just utilizing the facilities for a
number of years now the Emma C board
have continued to work with the ymax
District Council towards one of their
goals which will note on slide three is
to develop a track around the perimeter
of the men were reserved for the
community used for recreation and
leisure and part of their plan looking
forward moving on to slide four is to
hopefully have a beautiful outlook
around the perimeter of the park
featuring ornamental trees and shelter
trees as part of that alright I'll move
on now to just a slide for it there just
picture of the autumn mental trees and
then also event on to slide 5 so what
has why mat district council a mandrill
sports club achieve so far
well since the storms of 2013 which
completely obliterated the surrounding
pine trees around the perimeter of the
park we've been working closely with the
with the council to obviously remove the
debris which by all accounts has has
gone now and what we live with is stance
which stumps and and gorse and broom
which obviously has established in years
it's we cannot maintain with their
current equipment so we're continuing to
move forward last year we things to
counsel opposite providing us with
funding of almost seven thousand dollars
were able to tidy up the southwest
corner of the park
which also involved the installation of
a culvert pot which therefore allows us
to put a track around the perimeter of
the park giving people with access our
next main target is to remove the stumps
and what I'll call the on the western
boundary near the center which is
happens to be alongside the residential
development trua are closed and mandible
Park it also has a significant access
for those from the Bradbury interstate
well which is also grown significantly
over the last few years so this year we
are we're looking for funding of six and
half thousand dollars to remove the
stumps in that corner and and doing that
we'll be able to also remedy the issue
of the fire hazard caused by gorse and
broom which grows around those stamps
and also create a nice entranceway for
people from those subdivisions to enter
into the manual Sports Club what we have
also achieved by the time of the words
funding from the council the outside
sources is plantings along the northwest
are along the western boundary and
preparation for the track and provide
some shelter and also we've had a kids
by track yet at the start so as I
mentioned we're looking for six thousand
dollars to continue this work around the
perimeter the park
another major Cobra well maybe requires
some ableton of the synergy between
seven and eleven thousand dollars to
redevelop the well it runs on the back
reserve it irrigates the farmland and
maintains effectively pasture for for
the for the countryside to ensure we're
not live with the dustbowl in that
region and also before they the other
sports clubs based in that area which a
mainly a question and an archery club as
well as you will noted
just want to give finally a big thank
you to you for what you've done for us
so far and I don't I know Dan sort of
your future but just a thumbs up from us
from or all the way you've done
happy to answer any questions that you
may have thanks Richard any questions
and thank you for the photos I'm each
councillor Blakey you're on mutual how's
that now good you're good yes hi Richard
talking about you will I appreciate it
had to be re thing he'd redevelop minded
to after the earthquakes but I've never
known of a will that is anticipating
every being redeveloped again every
three to four years can you and enlarge
on that yeah yeah it's it's a probably
very on the side of safety and that is a
can that we did not know it's going to
be very sandy and that the sand has
effectively filled the bottom of the
well and needs to come out and we
understand that this potentially could
be ongoing it is a little bit of a
guesswork as to whether how often it
needs to be done weird on the side of
safety it says it's going to be
somewhere between three to four years
that it needs to be redeveloped so while
we've just given you given you a figure
it really is a little bit big estimate
even even in the actual estimate of
redeveloping the well there's something
that well developed a city look it's
really had a messy and we cannot I give
you an exact figure based on the fact we
just don't know until we're doing the
job thank you thanks Richard Castle duty
you're not mute your your are mute windy
oh thanks Richard thanks for all the
work you you do and floor submission is
free well done and I just asked
wondering about the pony club and they
have they settled down a bit because we
haven't sort of called up sentimental
they resigned to the fact that they
weren't going to do anything there for a
while until they they can't well gets
repaired
yeah we've kept in contact with the
Eaton Pony Club and constantly and in
regards to the world I'll see they were
very disappointed the timing was not
great for them it collapsed and in
January and and the heat of the season
and they hadn't been coming up at the
end of February and as I'm sure you
mostly probably could understand it's
not great for horses to be on hard soil
and as a result they had a significant
number on standard entries pull out
because of the risk associated with
running horses on the hog country so it
really just shows how crucial that
irrigation that probably at the back is
as to us and moving forward for it to be
used for recreational purposes and we've
been working closely honestly with with
Grandma cloud as well in regard to this
well and he has easily been kept up late
with information we got it as well so
the other question is they were going to
hold another event sort of an autumn
that they'd have to be cancer was there
cancer by : 19 they have more or less
they have three major events we knew one
is the end of February the pony club had
to be a major one end of June early July
which they are still planning to go
ahead with at this stage and the other
major event is at the end of August
obviously the pressure in terms of
ground conditions around that time care
is not too bad and we're not really rely
on our irrigation at that point but if
we won't need to when you need to
maintain pasture on top of this country
to make sure we aren't we don't end up
with a Dust Bowl especially considering
the large subdivision that has taken
place along a western boundary and I've
no doubt if we were to maintain that
pasture we would wind up with dust and
significant issues with the resistance
and those subdivisions mix counts of
duty counts Urbana is Richard with cover
19 obviously it's had a major effect on
a lot of sporting codes and as with the
council I'm sure you've had to look at
your budgets going forward for the next
12 months are you able to give us a
picture of how amendable is doing in -
in light of what's happened in the last
few months and what you see is the
issues with budget going forward if
there's any areas you need to comment on
yeah obviously you've got me very short
on the pace here and we're a little bit
we haven't really had a chance to even
have a board meeting over since the the
code 19 break-in period
so I'm a little bit unknown but from
what I'm seeing our main concern is
probably going to be a club sport is it
in particular the winter codes is it
going to get underway
that has a major effect on income in
terms of maintaining a clock yes which
is separate to the reserve budget which
arthas's for so that income that we
receive from the sports as to maintain a
clubhouse areas and even that the costs
the ongoing costs which won't go away
with that but yes sir I can't give you
much more than it at this stage we're
really really on trying to find out when
club sports going to get underway and
obviously want to figure it's going to
have a little stay on the track thank
you
that's we'll have to pause at the I
guess if you could just keep us informed
through counselor duty she's every upon
that being able sports cuddlier it would
be great but good Christian counts about
it but we're but don't keep us on track
on time we'll run over so look Richard
thank you for your submission and we
appreciate the thought that the sports
club have gone into it and presenting
there and you today just to give you an
idea time we will be having
deliberations between the 26th and 28th
of May on air in your plane and then
look to adopt on the 16th of June and
after that we'll be in a position to
communicating our decisions but on
behalf of the council where thanks to
the main table Sports Club for all the
work that you all do on behalf of our
community it's a great facility thank
you Dan thank you very much and I
promise windy I'll have a shape by the
time to see you next time okay I'll keep
it on thank you thank you
Cheers thank you I'm tier just an update
whose we got Martin mr. mayor I just got
a message from Martin saying
unfortunately he's having problems with
the zoom and he will submit his
submission via papers to the council and
you so this is very sorry that you
cannot join the hearing it's no trouble
that happens we appreciate that okay so
the next on their list is siftin hawk
are they waiting in their waiting room
yes tomorrow so if they're really really
show them through hello if we got Paul
dear
he's just connecting to audio I'll give
them a minute or two Joey in there as
well
hi Joanne how are you are you at the
moment
hi Joanne it's good to see you we can
see you you can hear us I can hear then
oh great you suck in here we can hear
you both so you you ready to go in terms
of your presentation so look just in
general these 10 minutes including
questions so we've read your submission
and thank you for that but if you want
to make major points the time is yours
that includes questions 18 minutes so
you want to leave some time for
questions it's up to you that I'm sure
there will be colleagues that would be
want to ask a few questions so I'll
leave that in your hand so is it all or
Joanne that's leading the submission
looks like Paul's still connecting to
the audio so I might start off of well I
could hear I could we continue cool yep
because can you hear me then yes we can
yes cool that's good okay thank you
right sorry orgy thank you very much
there I'm just talking to the draft plan
and for next year or later this year
next year then I'm just a rough outline
of the Sefton hall and it was reasonably
damaged during the 2010 2013 earthquakes
and we had a detailed engineering report
and done sort of after that when we all
work with the insurance company
and they basically wanted that to find
out
how much the repairs were going to cost
for the hall itself and so basically
that was done in near the end of 2013
and it pretty much come over there kept
from their payout so to do the reappear
was going to cost more than three
hundred thousand so they basically this
what they pay to see out on and so with
that we just set for a couple of years
basically waiting for all the repairs
and whatever was happening in the in the
wider area of Canterbury so in 2015 we
sort of started working with an
engineering company GHD and Christchurch
to get a set of plans on what the hall
structurally needed to be needed to
actually bring it up to the council
speak and with these plans that we were
able to just to get some idea of the
costing of that pretty much it coming
out around between six and seven hundred
thousand dollars to do the repairs that
was just from a couple of contractors
and then we sort of thought well we were
going to get this sort of money so it's
sort of slowed us up quite a bit at that
stage and both contractors said on the
equates that the the hole should be
replaced there was that many sort of
hadn't costs so to bring it back up to
the council speak speak we would
probably be looking at at least another
hundred thousand more so total would
have been hidden up to that 750 thousand
so we decided that tongue will just hold
back on all that for a couple of years
and try and work out what and which
direction were we going to go whether
we're going to start raising funds for
that amount and just do a do the repairs
or should we
go back to the community and see if it's
feasible to actually build a new hall
which we did we we called a community
meeting and that from there it was sort
of quite a bit of talk of which
direction we should go and who in the
hall mr. macey told everyone that the
halls owned by the community so we need
to make as a community we needed to make
the decisions so by the end of the
meeting we decided that we need to do a
feasibility study and pretty much very
much to work out there I'm costing and
everything from there so that was
completed that basically took up all
last year and was completed in January
of this year so at this after that and
we had a meeting with and with you Dan
and a couple other council members and
some of the committee I'm just just to
get a feeling of what the council
laris to do and where we sort of go from
there so at the end of that meeting we
sort of come up that we all had to sort
of call it we had to call it the compare
basically the committee had to call a
community Yarmouth and meeting again to
actually present the feasibility study
and the recommendation from that study
was to build a new hall so we were
hoping to have that all sort of
completed by now that due to the virus
and the meetings we haven't been able to
actually do that so at this stage we're
just sitting and we've we've put in a
application for the draft annual plan to
the council and we're just speaking on
that now so pretty much at best this
stage
err questions for starters if we decide
to go ahead with the new hall and we
would be probably looking at doing it in
the domain rather than knocking now all
over and building it there so what would
the council's thought beyond that okay
so so so just just to clarify Paul we're
not in a position to answer that today
we appreciate the questions you've posed
but we will deliberate on those points
and come back to you
what colleagues are here to do is to
we're to hear from you and then answer
any probe perhaps if you've got time for
some questions there may be some
questions and then we'll be able to come
back to you after considering those
points that you've made did you have
anything else she wanted to raise before
I open it to questions okay no sir I
assume you all got a copy of the
feasibility study and the recommendation
and there was two let's rebuild on a
different site and the most obvious site
would be up in the domain which is a
council owned property it would be
basically funded the new build would be
funded by a sale from the Old Hall in
another building that we have for sale
plus the insurance payout plus some if
we can get external funding from such
like lotteries or Russia or something
like that it plus some community
fundraising so the basically what we're
looking from here your decision you know
I know it's later date as would dick
help happy hour the council if we did do
that what would be an exit plan should
the community be unable to you know
maintain this building and you know or
just what sort of support or would you
be happy to give regardless of whether
its financial or whatever just basically
your thoughts and
you basically yeah I see counselor duty
hitter you know she did right counselor
Brian did first but just just to clarify
we're not in a position to answer you
those points do we will come back to you
on those so for the purpose of my
colleagues it's just to provide carat
clarification questions or questions in
general so but we will come back to and
a fully considered minute so please be
assured that it thank you might your
comments so firstly county councillor
Brian followed by counselor duty Thank
You casa Brian thanks for that I've seen
the documentation cricketers briefly
mentioned here for advanced are you with
discussing cricket this proposal I'll
just briefly discuss with them Chris
Road and this sort of passing we haven't
had a formal meeting yet with the
planners as soon as we can sort of get
over this fluorescing and we'll bring
all the clubs together
and then just get their views on it and
we want to do that before we go back to
the community meeting thank you
Cassidy T thank you do you envisage
having a hall as large moment I know
having just done a you know there
recently just that acoustics and they
all that's wonderful do you envision
having something as large as that yes
we'd be looking at a hall that would be
big enough to two for the school what
the school would need and also for what
the indoor bowls and any other sort of
community groups in here and then the
indoor bowls are is a big user of the
hall and we want to sort of catered for
them and hopefully by having a sort of a
new a new who in plenty of room it'll
boost the club in in the hall itself by
having a new rule would would really
boost the community as well thank you
thank you
cancer pileup
Youth thank you very much for your in
very very professional submission it was
a pleasure to read and my question is
about the Ministry of Education comment
was there a possibility explored about
having the hall on the school grounds in
a ministry of education contribution
seeing that Hall is not suitable for the
children now you see the Education
Department was approached and pretty
much say don't want to know any anything
about the hall they are unable to build
a new hall on the school site because of
the actual ratio of the buildings to the
school area so basically the only use
the only thing they would do they'd be
prepared to maybe pay a nominal rental
for the use of the new or the repeat
hall and just subsequently the school is
happy with the proposed change of
location and it hasn't been sort of run
up past and they're probably heard at
Justin's and say and but I think at this
stage it will be up to the community in
muhammediye
to we the whole goes thank you Thank You
councillor Stewart a quick question
Thank You mr. Muir does the Sifton hall
committee or the groups that you might
it might come together to use or support
a new hoard have any ability to serve us
solo interest or interest-free loan
sorry can't I
I can't really answer that because I'm
not too sure of what sort of how the
advances go there it's starts at that
point thank you and if it comes to that
so through the point we can discuss
later on look thank you Joe in and in
Paul for your submission I agree with
counsel about it was a very professional
submission
and we do appreciate the work that
you've been doing you know a number of
us I think was myself accounts the
Reedman that attended the meeting the
end suit me appreciate the patient
enthusiasm from the community so look
thank you
just to let you know our process we will
be considering de little deliberating on
the annual plan between the 26th and
28th of May we'll look at adopting Aryan
you're playing on the 16th of June and
then we will be in a position to
communicate our decisions hostess but in
the interim I will follow up with Chris
and grant because there were some points
that we did agree at that meeting about
assisting you with those community
meetings I'll follow that up with them
thank you both thank you all right we're
at break time here just in terms of
Jillian do you know when she
Oh hold on Thank You V once just lift
already invited it in mr. mee
okay I'm Julian hold on here we are
please join us wait for nibble here is
Phillips disappeared now hi Jillian
how are you you'd like to just unmute
hello can you hear us okay oh yes right
great being early so we decided we were
a bit ahead of time so we thought we
would take you now it's okay with you so
just to be clear you've you're familiar
with how we run hearings having been to
a few in the past so up to ten minutes
including questions we've received your
submission and consider that there has
been read so any major port main points
you'd like to raise from that the ten
minutes is up to you but it's including
questions if time permits thank you
so we're in your hands thanks Jillian
everybody and thank you for the
opportunity to submit verbally even
though it is by the internet so it's um
it's wonderful that we now have a five
diversity officer employed by the
council and in this enables an
opportunity or the council to heart they
can have an active role and assisting
landowners who have indigenous
vegetation on their properties and I
understand of course at the moment the
councillors is looking hard if the
budgets and um there are likely to be
some budgetary costs caps considered so
I'd like to emphasize the
the importance of maintaining sufficient
ongoing funding in the fund that you
have at the moment to ensure that the
well really that the landowners are able
to get assistance for either the main
areas are these
[Music]
there's probably looking at relatively
small amounts of money in local and
sorry excuse me just Jillian and tier
could you please put a mute yell thank
you
sorry Jillian please conclude continue
sorry there were simply small amounts of
money and overall council budget but and
very important that they are there
because of course when some of these
remnants are gone then they cannot be
replaced and I've mentioned in previous
submissions some of those important
dryland agreements that we had within
our district so any money can be really
targeted and being you know really good
value or for what have the cheese
especially with the biodiversity officer
that we now have in the council so
funding is this funding is very much
portal out of the equation looking after
the infamous vegetation many associated
with fauna what goes with it quite often
so there needs to be a specific fund for
the education and honor and at the
moment there is an existing fund which
is shared between vegetation heritage
buildings and notable trees so a
specific fund for each of these would
ensure sort of certainty for everyone
who made rather than having of one fund
that was open for applications from
three different areas so I looked at
page 12 on me
draft annual payment budget we are even
looking at music outcomes and the - I
looked at there were these indigenous
flora and fauna and the heritage
buildings and I looked at the outcomes
that were wanted for heritage buildings
and that was they are protected and the
cultural cultural heritage links with
our past are preserved I mean I looked
at what was written for the indigenous
vegetation and it looked about
conservation and restoration being
encouraged now I can see a direct
parallel between the heritage buildings
and the indigenous vegetation in that
one was looking after our cultural
heritage and the other one is looking
after our natural heritage so I've
suggested in my submission some wording
to replace the existing wording for
indigenous education which really works
in parallel with the heritage our
cultural heritage science and finally in
my last paragraph I have just once again
stressed the importance of protect a new
existence of national education and once
again for a comparison with heritage
buildings yeah without ever consider
replica buildings to be anything so
thank you for your time thank you
Juliana thank you for your thoughtful
submission any questions from colleagues
cats uh Stewart thank you Samir and
Thank You Julian for your submission do
you have any views on what sort of sums
should go into a secret fund for a
vegetation issue of advocated there
that was very difficult to say at the
moment that was of course the
biodiversity opposite has only really
started a job and has not had an
opportunity to go out and meet some of
the landowners and look at some of the
sites and indeed assess what needs to be
done but so I can't really put a figure
on it it would be up to the biodiversity
officer when she has little does it have
to feel more size to have a better idea
of it but it's not going to be hundreds
of thousands of dollars and anything
like that that's why I said you know
relatively small amounts of money and
indeed can be very targeted and so you
know very good baby
between distinct ending answers money
yes thank you do you think I record that
it was $15,000 a year used to go into
that contestable fund across the three
funding targets if it was a separate
fund for vegetation he's thinking about
in that sort of range fifteen thousand a
year that could go into a separate fund
for SN A's and vegetation protection I
would say it will take at least that to
be realistic if there were San Jose
fencing projects and things like that
you know that's when they are done also
you know they're done now of they're
done later is so I would say it would
need at least 15,000 not more
I think you cancer Stewart any further
questions well Thank You Gillian you've
made very clear points and it was a very
clear submission so we appreciate that
just to let you know we'll be
considering and deliberate deliberating
on and you'll plant all submissions
between the 26 to 28 of May will be then
looking at adopting the annual pain on
the 16th of June will then be in a
position to communicate with you in the
community what our decisions are but
thank you for your patient and interest
in this area and your time today and
presenting your submission thank you
thank you
Thank You TIA
so we are now ready for mr. Freeman he's
still in the waiting room sure we just
break for a minute yep
[Music]
[Music]
okay so Peter you you and Gary both
jointly doing the presentation I'll be
leading Gary's here as moral support
okay we're in your hands Peter for the
next ten minutes thank you very much
thank you I'll trade down councillors
thank you for having us this afternoon
oh and Jim as well mr. Baumer and thank
you for the opportunity to make this
submission you received our submission
so I do not intend going over the whole
lot again because that'll just bore you
so the crooks the matter is the South
drop Community Sports Club is gonna have
a shortfall this year for the actual
funding to operate the Sports Club the
club is as it says down here over the
year we actually horst about round about
13,000 people some of those are
developed will admit that so with in
between the sports of all the sports we
do host and other things so go the
cricket club they totally the netball
Special Olympics contra country click
cricket players some they're actually
netball meet the Burnside netball
sometimes meet the North County
basketball have some of their meetings
we understand will probably miss some of
those when the new multi sports facility
comes up but pétanque as you know gather
the North Country Sports Trust for
primary school they have rugby there
every Friday we have several school uses
the facilities new life school civil
defence welfare as you know I've used
and hopefully welcome
don't have too many cases to use a
facilities again but the other half when
the atom need to do so the model
airplane playing club and the fire
brigade use it for training facilities
and then on the Saturday Ranga you're a
cricket so our laws over the 12 months
we've got some very good usage of their
like so
Erasmus about 13,000 people per annum
there's a the sports club is a separate
entity to all those previously was owned
by a lot of those different associations
but due to the recent financial
difficulties it has been taken over the
sole financial responsibility of the
Saracens Rugby Club that is not a
position the Rugby Club wanted sake on
board and is a necessity not by desire
they spoiled the Rugby Club house as you
can see by the submission he said its
30,000 over the last two and a half
years we've actually the rugby clubs
just actually had to tip in another
eight thousand dollars to fund the
immediate needs of the sails Brook
Community Sports Club we believe that
this force the Community Sports Club is
a very miss necessary facility for the
south of Rangoon it is a world use
facility as in outside the challenge
we've got is the actual clubhouse there
is not really fit for purpose in
previously we have gained quite a bit of
income by renting it out we used to get
a regular income from the likes of say
the blood transfusion service they have
now stopped using us because of the
ambience the toilet facilities the
heating the windows being a single
glazed and had not just been suitable
for their purposes
we've also a lot of a lost a lot of
others uses we used to rent it out for a
lot of social activities there no longer
not many people use it we down to just a
couple events per annum and that was all
impacted on our funding and ability to
run the facilities from the actual
changing sheds if it ends to been down
the changes shows are not fit for
purpose they are single-sex because they
have assured showers the changing sheds
are not big enough for even
and under 15 rugby team other sports do
use it cricket but it's not big enough
for a cricket team's upstairs we used to
be able to rent out for martial arts
that stops or twelve months ago just
over now because again that was found
that facilities were not good enough and
there's a lot of work media doing on
that initially the Rugby Club did put
aside some funding some monies to fund
the renovation of the changing sheds
however once the exploratory work was
carried out it is found as that is way
beyond the means of the rubber club and
all the sports clubs in particular you
will see we've done some very
preliminary estimates for the sports for
the changing sheds and for the clubhouse
for renovation or repairs that is the
discussion and internally by the sports
club and the affiliate clubs
that's a layer today we do not intend
bringing that up really particularly now
because full cost benefit full costings
have not been carried out on that the
immediate challenge we have is
continuing to provide a facility for the
community beyond end of June beginning
of July this year the virus has hit you
and everybody else as we all know but
unfortunately it hit us a beginning of a
biggest income-generating period which
is the Rugby season and the best case
scenario currently is a rugby whilst our
end of June so middle of July a very
short season okay so they chaw
submission Peter yep only along with a
written submission you've already
received thank you thank you well thank
you for your submission points questions
of colleagues accounts very concerned
you missed me Peter I think I asked this
question last year but I just can't
remember the
that is medicine the insurance bill is
$17,000 which seems an extra nominal and
I just compared compared to other clubs
that I've seen on balance sheets
it just seems well they're the
proportion and I'm thinking my about so
that we can you jog my memory place
certainly and that doesn't actually even
include earthquake cover for the main
clubhouse we had to drop that jutsu cost
so we don't actually have earthquake
cover for the main Club X that's 17,000
we actually only last week went back to
our broker and and another broker and
got a reported and that is the best core
we can get we just had to pay six months
with reduced and and that is actually
just less than seventeen we're going
down to about correct me if I'm wrong go
about 15 and a half 16 isn't it though
yeah over 15 now 16 is what we just
managed to get it down to but as I said
that does not include earthquake cover
for the main building okay thank you
thank you
Casa Bella yes hello Peter hello Gary
very good to see you and just wondering
when you mentioned about the whole delay
of sport and everything and that's
impacting on every club and in the whole
country has there been any conversations
with the government about any assistance
for sport going forward to try and meet
some of those costs that are going to
absolutely drastically reduce your
budget the men's a now if you apparently
have done some discussions but we have
no had no progress with that whatsoever
and there are if you have gone for the
wage subsidy and country gone for the
wage subsidy that's not something that
applies to us well it no longer place
was thinking counselor duty followed by
cancer treatment just a query please the
old changing rooms and in the club area
is there enough room for changing rooms
to be added onto the your do you require
to rebuild the old Oh fold and building
our preference would actually and we've
had some preliminary plans done is to
actually locate the mediation to the
clubhouse
because the existing clubbers not only
are they not fit for purpose they're
also a health and safety problem because
the G a B the juniors in particular have
to cross the main access road to the car
parking facilities to the rear of the
clubhouse and every time they come in
and out they have to cross over that
understand things Thank You councillor
Edmund I think you missed me I think you
paid up for annex one submission they
clubhouse in the challenging sheets
what sort of booth quite writings that I
have quite camera I actually don't know
the specific ratings on those but I can
tell you from my own experience I would
have thought they changing sheds in
particular got a very very law of
creating we have got problems with water
ingress we have got problems with some
differential settlement and we got some
puzzles with some leaks that's one of
the problem one of the challenges with
the existing facility we were the first
to admit that some of the ongoing
maintenance has been neglected over the
last ten years or so and that has been
due to a fiscal was not be Delta forty
basically and we've done the main what
is the major but what about the club
rooms do you know anything of there no
other insurance insuring them for the
earthquake because we can't afford it
that would forever wasn't I can't
exactly remember off the top thing is
about an extra six or seven thousand
dollars a year to include earthquake
cover just for the clubhouse
I could add later when when they change
the hair we had to insure a property
like everyone does you know about 25,000
the fall is quite inclusive earthquake
cover as well on both buildings so I
decided to count around fifteen or
sixteen we we couldn't afford to pay the
whole lot so we did away with the
earthquake cover on the
mine clubrooms purely because it's a big
wooden building and it doesn't suffer
any damage so dentally pretty we just
felt as a committee we had their
summaries quite cover then that's when
on the old building so because it's just
purely for cost it's scary castle award
thank you I I like the idea I have a
question for you but I really like the
idea I think you really do offer a great
service and the birth of rugby in touch
rugby so baby and so my question to you
is have you got any idea how you can
raise some funds to put it you need to
put up a new changing shared next to the
main building that's the best option for
you so can you go to charity oh no you
can't at the moment but so there's a lot
of foundation Pub charities and a lot of
the other trusts that you could apply
maybe for funds to do that build and
repairs that is definitely something
that we are planning to started doing as
I said we've already had some draft
designs done for putting their changing
chairs next to the clubhouse we're gonna
rise in my submission to a cost benefit
because we're gonna prove to router
various others and lotteries as to what
what the costs are going to be and what
and well the process we've been through
to shores as those are required we also
have we're in a bit of a two-edged sword
situation here where by the Rugby Club
dipper some funds to one side to start
doing that initially was to do the
repairs to the old club or the old
changing shirts but that has fruit
proven economical so to build another
one we did but that money is slowly
being the way as I said 38,000 the last
two and a half years their Rugby Club is
up to support and subsidize the other
sports and the users of the actual says
Brook Community Sports Club well thank
you for your answers look thank you both
Gary and Peter for your submission this
afternoon on behalf of Southport and
Sports Club
it will get careful consideration during
our deliberations which to be held
between the 26th to 28th of May we will
look to them adopt air in your clean on
the 16th of June and will be in the
position to communicate our decisions
with you in the community after this so
not thank you both very much for your
time and for your commitment to the
south court sports clubs thank you all
very much for your time we appreciate it
thank you thank you thank you
in colleagues we've reached the end of
hearing of submissions is now what no
one else I've missed the Atia have a
realist it's great so thank you and look
like this has been our first time using
zoom for this sort of hearing so it's
been I found it very good that rest of
you here too so I thank you for the
spirit in which we've run this today can
I especially well like we knowledge a
community and the submissions that
they've put forward and but also to us
particular thanks to our staff for all
the work they've done putting our
information together getting us into
this position booking all the spots and
for making sure that the technology
works so particular thanks to the
governance scene to work on staff for
all the work and that's may send in to
Helene as well at in the which leads our
in your planning process so thank you
everyone and is it mentioned we will
come back to deliberate on this between
the 26th to 28th of May I'm sure I'll be
seeing you all in due course in
especially for our meeting next Tuesday
thank you everyone
oh sorry Jim Jay Dana we still and are
we still being recorded gain human I
think that would be good yes
[Music]
[Music]